hey everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host atlas i am super pumped to
be talking about all things
science fiction we have robert j sawyer
joining us on the show
hi rob how you doing atlas thanks so
much for coming on the program
an absolute pleasure i'm delighted to be
here i'm so excited rob's background is
so
epic he's a 24-time sci-fi author
translated across
over 20 languages winning myriad awards
including hugo and nebula with a deep
focus on the nature of reality
consciousness and the future of humanity
you can find his links in the bio below
to all of his books at sfrider.com
also his twitter profile this is gonna
be
epic let's start things off with this
biggest question
what is the nature of reality and
consciousness
well they're obviously intertwined i
think if there was a lesson
of quantum physics it is that there is
no reality no one single concrete
reality
until a conscious observer comes along
this is so counter-intuitive to
everything that humanity believes since
the dawn of time
we talk as you know a child is growing
up a child gains
a notion of object permanence at some
point that just because
they don't see the object it's been put
away in a chest of drawers
the object is still there it has
material reality its
existence is independent of the child
well we consider that the normal
evolution
of our of our intellectual abilities as
we age in our lifespan
but it turns out that that is a crock in
fact
the object has no permanence it is not
there
until it is being observed and so the
two are
so intertwined reality and consciousness
that you really can't ask what one is
without answering it's the other one
the consciousness the
awareness the observer the witness
is in many ways the
nature of reality and
that the world
of form or physicalism
that this is
appears as that and
that this may even be
only one of so
many possible creation designs
and that how do you take
that perspective in while you do your
sci-fi
authoring right you know the fundamental
question about writing
science fiction is are you writing the
future
or are you writing a future we take as a
given that started
at this juncture whatever moment in time
it is right now
that there's a panoply of possibilities
in front of us
any number of possible futures and yet
we have
sort of hard-coded into the way we think
about things that the present
is the one and only present and the past
is the immutable one and only past
well again this last century of physics
has blown that out of the water
there are endless almost certainly i
mean we don't know 100
for sure but everything that we find in
terms of modern physics seems to
indicate
that there are as many nows as
as you could arbitrarily want up to an
infinite number
of nows of parallel realities of
versions of reality where
donald trump didn't become president
where instead it was hillary clinton
versions of reality going back where al
gore became president instead of
uh george w bush versions of reality
going back
where the french uh controlled north
america instead of the english
all of those have equal validity
to the particular idiosyncratic
random draw from the hat that we happen
to think of as the one we exist in
i also frequently
do the the
creation design and simulation game
where i
go and i i visualize what
the north american continent would look
like
if the if we didn't come over here
right exactly yeah you know i mean i
live in canada right
and you know the american manifest
destiny american the slogan was i don't
know if they still teach this in
american schools but we canadians are
vividly conscious
of the american manifest destiny slogan
which is 54 40 or bust
which is the 54th parallel and 40
minutes of latitude
up north i live down at 44 degrees
latitude right i live below the 49th
parallel because
toronto and southern ontario sticks down
along the contours of the great lakes
if america had succeeded in its manifest
destiny canada
would essentially not exist we would
just be a frozen tundra north
uh if of course uh the europeans hadn't
come over
just half a millennium ago almost no
time at all
in terms of human history if the
europeans hadn't come over we would have
a
rich and vigorous array
of aboriginal and indigenous cultures
still alive in north america
a very very different and very
worthwhile and very
uh wonderful uh north america
very different than the one you and i
happen to acknowledge as
our consensus reality at the moment
and like you describe any of the
past the possibility space in many ways
it's like a
a bayesian cloud of probabilities it's
kind of like the
quote electron cloud and the quantum
mechanical understanding
and that there are these denser
areas where there's a higher likelihood
for
civilization to evolve towards yeah
that's right
yeah i i'm sorry i didn't mean to
rupture but you're absolutely right i
mean if you ask
based on american history what's the
likelihood that the current president of
the united states
would be a lawyer it's extremely high
most presidents
have been lawyers that's a bayesian
likelihood that's the
principle of mediocrity what's the
likelihood that it would be a reality
show host given that until
25 years ago there was no such thing
as a reality show host you would have to
say we live in an extraordinarily
unlikely universe in which a newly
created job
reality show host gives rise to the most
powerful
becomes most powerful person in the
world we are bucking the bayesian trend
enormously in that particular
and in many others and many others you
know where
there are those who would say we were
way overdue
for a pandemic right way over a century
given the density of our populations and
the interconnectivity of our
international travel why didn't we get
hit by something
you know really bad in the 1960s who
knows we buck the bayesian trends all
along
all the time which is one of the good
arguments that somebody is tweaking
our reality that the parameters we're
seeing are not the ones that would be
drawn at random from the likely
bayesian space of probabilities but some
of them are such complete outliers that
you gotta say
who the heck is is loading our dice when
we throw and make this reality
yeah seeing things like the big decision
tree and the big cloud of possibilities
and then also
having a a level of awareness around the
eradication of suffering and the
maximization of well-being
and prosperity and abundances is
critical i'm curious i want to
i want to play with you on this
do we all come from the same source
so that's a really interesting question
because quantum mechanics can be very
solid cystic which says of course you we
do because you're a figment of my
imagination
i am the only source i am the only
observer in this universe
and everything that you know you are
either a
an aspect of me or a non-player
character you're a philosopher zombie
i have consciousness you do not you just
pretend or you look like
you act like you have consciousness but
don't really
so from that point of view one can argue
you know very solipsistically of course
everything comes from that single source
um
if you take though that there are in
fact almost eight billion
distinct separate individuals
it does get kind of interesting that we
have any sort of
consensus reality you know william
gibson my fellow canadian science
fiction writer
uh talks about what you know he called
cyberspace being a
consensual illusion consensual meaning
that you and i and everybody else
had agreed to visualize
cyberspace the way that he described it
it nothing at all to do with in fact the
photons or the electrons moving in the
fiber optics or the
or the uh you know wire cables that
actually make up the internet but we
visualize it
and we agree on that so do we all come
from the same source
they're either eight billion different
sources of reality and it's astonishing
that
there's any continuity of moment to
moment or there's only one source of
reality which is either i'm a figment of
your imagination or you're a figment of
mine
i don't know which is more correct
except as mr spock once famously said
you know
i am convinced that i exist you know the
kagito ergosum in vulcan is
i know i'm here i'm here so if one of us
is not really the source it's got to be
you
because i know it ain't me
i'm curious how this resonates with
you the
idea of coming from the same source
meaning that the observer is
shared across all of us yeah i think
there's a lot of sense that that has to
be true
we seem to have you know we argued you
and i just a few minutes ago about or
discussed object permanence
but we do seem to you know i can
remember
i'm 60 years old six zero i can't
remember back 60 years but i went back
55 years since
just a few things and i can remember
back 40 years in an enormous amount of
detail
and if you let's go back 20 years at age
that you'll remember
if we go back 20 years you and i will
compare notes
and we may or may you know as memories
famously fallible
disagree about some details but then we
would go and both look at wikipedia and
find out oh yeah you were right or i was
right you know
it really did go down this way oh yeah
that's the way it was
so there's definitely a consensus
even if you're collapsing the wavefront
separately from me collapsing the
wavefront
somehow there's a holographic
reality building up where your
collapsing wavefronts and mine coincide
to make a reality that you and i can
have a conversation about
and i think that's extremely profound
and at the level of discussing the
observer phenomenon in quantum physics
there's not a lot of discussion of yeah
but how come
two people you know theoretically two
people
could simultaneously each be you know
one light second away from
schroedinger's
cat box one to one second to the left
and one light second to the right
so they both look simultaneously one
second later is the cat dead or alive
well
why is there consensus why do two
observers
ultimately share uh a version of reality
so they can
interact so they can have a conversation
so they can actually say okay i'm gonna
mail you something
and you're gonna get it in the mail
we've only
really just begun to deal with the fact
that
the observer effect has to be spread
across
the current 8 billion people who exist
now are the 100 billion
homo sapiens have existed since the dawn
of time
and usually what is
meant by love is awareness that we
share that witness we share
i think yeah yeah you know it fascinates
me empathy
fascinates me love fascinates me because
there's always this reductionist
tendency in evolutionary thinking
to reduce well you know of course
there's attachment to your children
because that
is your selfish genes making sure that
your children live long enough to have
children
but it you know i and a lot of my
friends
i have to say it's a very almost
pandemic among science fiction writers
they're an awful lot of us who don't
have any children by choice
you know i 20 years ago voluntarily
chose to get sterilized
i got a vasectomy now what the hell is
up with that
what possible evolutionary forces
resulted in a sane
human being choosing to absent
himself for himself themselves from the
reproductive rat race
clearly there's and yet i love my nieces
i love my none of whom are biologically
related to me but i love them
i love a lot of my fellow men and women
i
love the human race i feel great empathy
and yet this reductionism this is all
about reproduction it's clearly not true
there clearly is such a thing as empathy
and even
love beyond this desire to reduce it to
just
a richard dawkins-esque selfish genes
scenario
and i would also be curious
how you feel about things like this
which is the sort of one of the
interpretations
of the way that consciousness is is that
consciousness
is across you and i is both this
blank pure bare empty
consciousness and then on the
on the rob sawyer side it's then
colored with your name
the identity you get a little sun
and on mine mine's colored with atlas
and it's colored with a tree and so
the idea is that this pure
consciousness is shared and then it gets
colored by the different experiences
how do you feel about that yeah you know
i mean
it's interesting you said the word color
because uh
i have three male cousins
all of whom are colorblind right so they
literally
see the universe even if we agree on you
know the physical
objects that around us here's a
microphone here's an easy chair there's
a book
there's a filing cabinet i got the back
reserve bookcase behind me
even if we agree we still don't see them
the same way
you and i presume and it's one of those
classic conundra
in uh theory of consciousness
to me when you held those up those look
like orange post-it notes
um but my perception of orange
or yellow and your perception of orange
yellow
we just have to agree as a
because there's no point in disagreeing
that they're the same
when in fact your orange might look like
migraine and vice versa and we
have no way of knowing we have to sort
of
take as a given that some aspects
of what we perceive communally
are identical observer independent
and some aspects very much depend on the
fact that well for one thing you know
without my glasses i couldn't have made
out the little detail of the sun or the
tree right
the sun and the tree are still there
apparently on your post-its
but i lack the physiological wherewithal
to proceed where was all
to perceive them until i add a
prosthetic to the case you
unless you're wearing a contact lenses
you have better vision than i
and have a different even a higher level
physical perception of reality than i at
my advanced
age am capable of anymore and yet we
assume
that the details that they're just
what you're seeing and what i see
essentially coincide
regardless of our physical abilities to
resolve what we're seeing yeah exactly
it's fascinating
and this
would be that shared
observer if we come from the same source
and we share the observer that is then
being colored all of these different
ways
it's having the different experiences
from our unique perspectives
and that i have this tree
be i'm being colored by this tree right
now you're being colored by the sun
you're colored as a science fiction
author
i'm colored as an interviewer right
there's seeing it from this perspective
where we share this pure
consciousness that is actually if we had
eight billion of these
that that field of consciousness would
be
that sameness but then the different
coloration and then those eight billion
would be one
one yeah but it would be a much bigger
square
right one of the fascinating things
about the wisdom of crowds is
if you ask people individually how many
jelly beans are in the jar
for instance right and you ask a hundred
people you can get numbers all over the
place and nobody
is good at guessing the number in the
jar but if you ask
a thousand people and aggregate their
answers
you get an extremely precise answer very
very close if not bang on
to the number of jelly beans actually in
the jar and
we talk about how interconnectivity to
the internet
brings human minds together in a way
that's kind of a super
consciousness but we very rarely ever
talk about it outside of the computing
metaphor
that there in fact are eight billion
human beings who
aggregate to a you know an almost uh
tiara dead
uh you know pardon yeah yeah trds rodon
a new sphere that we are this
elaborate thing that you know there's
okay the average iq is a hundred
by definition but there are eight
billion
times a hundred iq points out there
which is
800 billion it took every one of my iq
points to do that math
eight and i uh a global iq of 800
billion
right which is an incredible uh entity
to be grappling with yeah yeah
another question would be
that is this
reality created by
that source as a creative exploration
so that's an interesting question if
there's a source to reality or
source to our consciousness does the
source
itself have consciousness
self-awareness volition needs and wants
or is it like asking you know the source
of the nile ultimately is where the nile
river flows from
and it's part of the hydrological cycle
and so forth
do raindrops you know which give rise to
rivers lakes and oceans uh do raindrops
actually have all of the same qualia
all of the same characteristics that an
ocean
has an aggregate and the answer is
clearly not raindrops don't have tides
raindrops don't have you know convection
zones within them
and oceans do so we don't know the
answer to your question
it's conceivable and of course the
religious perspectives
of course we're all atoms of god we've
all come as little
uh fragments and that god is
fractal in the sense or we're fractals
of god
that you zoom in on us you find
consciousness you pull back
and you find consciousness now is
consciousness on a
universal scale fractal that no matter
whatever level you zoom in on it there's
self-awareness
or is it hierarchical so that only at
certain levels of instantiation roughly
two meters tall let's say that you
actually have consciousness
and that our subatomic particles don't
so pan psychism is out if you say that
and the whole larger being may lack
consciousness as well
one of the things that's required for
instance for our
kind of consciousness and it may be a
biological remnant of our evolution
is a perspective a point of view i'm
looking at this i'm concentrating on you
right now i'm not
blissfully unaware except in this odd
circumstance that i've actually
can see that there's you know pine wood
paneling on the
cabinetry behind me but if i wasn't
looking at myself in a monitor
i'm blissfully unaware of more than 180
degrees of reality behind me visually at
least
what is the reality of the super
consciousness or the source
it's eminently debatable at this point
and i think all
positions are defensible because we
don't have enough information
yet
it deeply relates to that earlier part
of our conversation
where the entire possibility space
of these creation designs is being
explored all of the different decision
trees even of
our one design of a reality are
all unfolding and that style of uh
imagination which is extremely
required for science fiction and
and even for children children are
that imagination when they are
when that is being fostered in them from
early childhood and then in a sense
if we're not vigilant what happens is
sometimes the
economic machinery can come and just
just completely
just squelch just destroy
that imaginative capacity and that
imagination is really what is
needed to tackle many of the biggest
challenges on
on the plan to think way outside of the
right box
and to think of things that have not yet
come
to pass yeah um you know we know
that dogs for instance dream you can do
experiments
you know one of the things that happens
when you sleep is you have sleep
paralysis which means you don't act out
what it is you're doing in your dream
right it's the difference between
walking
and dreaming of walking in dreaming of
walking you don't walk
and we consider it a pathology if you
are in fact
sleepwalking if you don't have dream
paralysis right that's wrong
but we can do the opposite we can take a
dog and we can do the neurological
chemical stuff to put an end to its
sleep paralysis
so you can see what the dog is dreaming
about and what is the dog dreaming about
the dog is dreaming about
chasing prey the dog is dreaming about
digging in the dirt
the dog never dreams about flying the
dog never shows any indication of
envisioning
something that isn't just reliving a
pleasant memory
or in a bad dream and living an
unpleasant memory but nothing i'm
nothing imaginative
nothing of saying this has never
happened before
but maybe could and obviously
dogs are not nearly as intellectually
sophisticated as art we are but
homo niendo tolensis our closest cousin
there's a lot of good evidence that
neanderthals had
very limited if any ability to think
imaginatively to think of things that
they hadn't already experienced
so that for instance we have a
continuous gradation
in the paleo archaeological record
of tool uh refinement
you'll see we keep making different and
different and different tools generation
by generation
neanderthals had an essentially static
industry they made tools the way beavers
made dams
right one beaver doesn't say oh you know
time to innovate
time to come up with that the you know
the frank lloyd wright of uh dams
uh i'm just gonna make a damn just like
my great great great great great
grandfather made a damn that's the only
thing i know how to do that's all
neanderthals
knew how to do but we had the ability to
look at
a flint nodule and see something in it's
like as michelangelo would say
you know how do you make david the
sculpture david well you look at the
rock
and you take away everything that isn't
david right that's an enormous
intellectual capacity that no as far as
we can tell
no other life form including even our
closest now extinct relatives and
neanderthals had that
capability to look and envision
something
that they hadn't already seen as
empirical reality
would you say that
similarly to how
we
at night we
dream a
a four dimensional so three space one
time
and we immerse ourself
in it in a first person perspective
would you say that that could be
what this is well it's interesting
because a lot of dreaming you're right
is first person
but there's also a lot of third person
perspective dreaming you see
yourself in a dream which is an
astonishing
intellectual leap right you don't think
of a
dog or a parrot or chimpanzee
visualizing itself
from a distance right it's all that
point of view perspective that very
tunnel vision perspective
so that reality the fact that we can
be a participant in a dream
while seeing ourselves at a distance is
that what's
evolutionary advantage there was to that
i don't know
the other aspect of dreams what we call
dream logic
things that don't make sense in a
newtonian world of physics
we accept and go with within a dream
and we just say yeah and it doesn't
cause a discontinuity
you don't wake wait about what's going
on here that can't possibly happen
nobody ever wakes up from a dream by
their brain sort of crashing and saying
wait i just envisioned something
that defies the laws of physics like me
flying or whatever right
you just go with that so there's some
very nimble quality
to human consciousness that's able to do
and i don't want to you know give any
credence necessarily to mystical thing
uh of out-of-body experiences but it's a
reality that we can visualize ourselves
in an out-of-body perspective and it's a
reality that
despite all of the training that starts
even pre-utero and you know pre-birth
in the uterus that starts with learning
about physics and you know
hearing noises hearing your mother's
pulse and feeling the world shake as
your mother walks around and so forth
all of that training newtonian physics
that you get from way before you're born
till the day you die
can go right out the window and your
brain still
goes along with it in dream state
is extraordinary i don't know what the
ramifications are
or why our brains evolve to be able to
do that
but the fact that the brain can function
with a version of reality that's at odds
with every
waking moment of reality it's ever
experienced is really quite mind-blowing
one of the hypotheses is the model based
reinforcement learning and monte carlo
tree search so that we're
constantly doing these simulations in
our minds about what the most
optimal path forward is for maximizing
our
future outcomes and it'd be
interesting to hear your perspective
about
the as above so below aphorism
that the same way
that we dream for
a third of our lives we sleep for a
third of our lives and we dream for that
period of time
that as we were discussing
the idea of that observer being shared
right the blank side of it that
this in itself coming from the same
source
the perennial wisdom across the planet's
traditions say that this is what god is
that god is the blank pure
consciousness that is then eternally
being colored
by these different yeah so how does that
how does that resonate
with you so it's a very interesting
question
because if god is such a loaded word
right you know
is god the the
far future descended of us high school
student who's doing his project or her
project
making a simulation in the laboratory
and if so you know are we only kind of
like a c plus right we're not like
the one that's going to go on to the
science fair we're the student who's
just getting by
made this universe with all of its it's
myriad
obvious uh structural flaws um
or is god this incredibly beyond
uh our comprehension uh super intellect
you know i talked
a few minutes ago about an iq
additive iq of the planet of 800 billion
uh iq points you know god would be
infinitely beyond that
um it really comes down to a matter of
personal
choice of whether you want to think
we're living in a
really cleverly designed
reality or a really shoddily
designed reality and
you can argue it kind of either way
but my argument would be my own personal
perspective is
if there's any design in this reality it
certainly isn't
omnipotent design it is fairly
contingent rough and ready uh
quick and dirty solutions to complex
problems design
which is very much what our evolutionary
history shows you know
i mean obviously i actually my hand
hurts today i don't know why i did
something to this right
my thumb here well you know 250 million
years ago was 400 million years ago
this was one of the uh supporting
rods in the pectoral fin of a fish
right it was never intended to be used
to hit the space bar
on a keyboard right half a billion years
later
and yet that's what i use it for now ow
it hurts
so this is a rough and ready solution to
the contingent problem of how do i
communicate without words
you know with a keyboard blah blah blah
it seems that an awful lot of our
reality is similar to that the
repurposing the reusing
of something rather than coming up with
an optimal
um bespoke solution to the actual
problem that's at hand
the
perennial wisdom across the planetary
spiritual traditions is
so deeply pragmatically beneficial as
well
for maximizing well-being because
typically what happens is like
when we recognize ourselves as this
one source that is
this pure consciousness that is then
being
colored there goes half our
consciousness
oops i bring you these 15
these 10 commandments
so it's having all these different
experiences right we just had the
experience of humor
right that's right and you know you just
had the experience of
uh one of the soft drinks and i just had
an experience of some tea
and we're having the experience of an
interview right now and
uh later we may have the experience of
some food and these types of things
and so the sort of way of understanding
it also
as an analogy is this sort of ocean
we use these analogies a lot the ocean
of the
pure consciousness that is undergoing
these different waves
of experience the rob sawyer wave this
atlas wave and then the
the soft drink the humor the tea all
these different waves of experience
and so one of the things that comes from
that process is
this sort of the sort of recognition
that
in a sense there's like a relaxing
that happens like the the egoic sort of
contracted uh separate
entity it dissolves
and the into
sort of what the the blink side is it
dissolves more and more into the blank
side and that doesn't mean that it's not
going to continue
getting really great colorations of
experience it's just that it becomes
more and more
aware of what its true nature is
and that then that true nature is argued
in many ways to be
a peace and a
happiness yeah right so i happen to be
in a closed room right now
there's oxygen molecules about you know
whatever it is 20
of them dispersed around mostly nitrogen
a little bit of carbon dioxide a few
other things in here
statistically there's oxygen all over
the room and i'm breathing just fine
here right
but there's a chance that it could all
end up in that corner
and i would suffocate we live in a world
of probabilities the probability of that
is such an outlier
that in all of my life i've never known
anybody who actually suffocated because
all the oxygen molecules
in whatever room they were in happened
to all go to one corner
they could there's a statistical
possibility we look at you know an
electron and we know an electron is a
cloud it's a probability
highly likely it's here a little less
likely it's here
very unlikely that it's over here but it
could be
that actually resonates with the
utilitarian notion
of good the greatest good for the
greatest number which is not an egoist
notion it's not the greatest good for me
and if it works out well for you
okay more so much the better i'm happy
to share but
it's got to be better for me than than
anybody else or i'm not interested no no
no
our morality is very much a statistical
morality or at least utilitarianism is
very much a statistical
morality just as our physical reality is
a statistical reality
by and large more than likely
the best outcome for me physically is
that the oxygen molecules
are distributed evenly throughout this
room and
ethically that throughout the eight
billion of us on the planet
most of us are doing better off than
those of us who don't happen to be doing
better off at that
you know particular juncture so it
really resonates for me that at both of
my parents i'll tell you this it
resonates for me because it's how i was
brought
up both my parents were professional
statisticians
they both taught at the university of
toronto and uh
it very much resonates for me that the
central concept
of physics that emerged during their
lifetime they were born in the 1920s
during their lifetime the central
concept that we live in is statistically
determined
as opposed to a concretely determined uh
universe and that morality is based
that what we seem to come around to
again to invoke mr spock the needs of
the many
outweigh the needs of the few that our
morality is also a statistical
morality uh you could say well it's just
coincidence one of the other
that they both happen to be you know
games of probabilities
but it also may just be a fundamental
reflection of the universe that we live
in
on an ethical and a physical basis
are both games of probability
does it does it resonate to
call the sort of wisdom from those
perennial traditions of this
being the source
or the god or the
eternity or the infinity that is
constantly
expressing itself in all of these
different creative ways
and that similarly to how we as above so
below we go into this
dream environment at night that we
as that source or that god create
this dream environment where we take on
these different perspectives
of the dream environment and immerse
ourselves
into it as a creative exploration
how does that resonate yeah it's very
interesting because used word god used
the word source
you know in science or in the law
for instance another interesting case
very
precise language has to be used
and you and i have to agree we have a as
they say the law a meeting of mines
if we don't agree on what one pound
of rice the green rice if we don't agree
on one pound of rice
what those terms mean we can't make a
contract that i'm gonna buy
and you're gonna sell me a pound of rice
if to me
rice is you know white rice and to you
it's brown rice and we haven't agreed
and
we don't have a meeting of mines we
don't use that term race to mean the
same thing
uh and in science of course it's all
about when i say you know
the universe and you say the universe
you know
we talk about island you know hubble
gave us the notion of the island
universe which we now have another word
for the galaxy
which wasn't you know a concept
separately right uh
that galaxies are sort of little island
universes but when we say the universe
would mean the sum total
of what well carl sagan called the
cosmos right
when we are imprecise with our language
in some ways that's a very positive
thing
because it allows everybody to be right
and feel good
but in other ways it keeps us from
actually having a meeting of minds
on what we're discussing so you know uh
everybody defines god or the absence of
god
to his or her their own satisfaction
and it's one of those very very slippery
terms whereas
everybody we have a general agreement
you know
um uh about
say what the united states is in terms
of geography
would you say that it would be possible
to
use the word god as the
as the observer
uh sure i think so i think so absolutely
as long as you know and you have
communication as long as any two people
agree about it
i mean um you know einstein famously
said god doesn't play dice with the
universe well he was wrong
uh stephen hawking the last paragraph of
um
of a brief history of time says if we
were to do this we would know the mind
of god
both of them were using the word god
einstein and hawking
i think in a way that uh a
judeo-christian
preacher theologian rabbi would not
recognize
as being the same concept so god is uh
is a very tricky term to invoke because
it's used
by even atheists to refer to
the sum total of uh
of the physical parameters that define
reality
i don't know if we ever will come up
with a consensus term
that everybody agrees with for what the
source the source is as good a term as
any
although up here in canada if it's the
same in the states radio shack
went out of business up here in canada
and the company that now
sells all that junk consumer electronics
is called the source
i'd like to think that whatever the
source really is it's something better
than selling me
overpriced flashlights and led clocks
you know
that's usually what the perennial
spiritual wisdoms point to
which is they just take their different
like flavors of
ice cream right but it's all ice cream
it's all ice cream that's right that's
right
and similarly they're different faces
different paths
to the one end well you know any i mean
in a very specific spiritual sense
christianity is
fascinating because it has the triune
god you know
oppenheimer named the trinity test site
after
trinity right that is an incredible
concept when you think about it
that we live in a reality where
one thing can also be three things this
is a christian
very direct christian dogma that god the
father
jesus christ and the holy spirit
are three different manifestations
or ways of perceiving one specific thing
the divinity of christ
in christianity is based on the
assertion not that
god that jesus is somehow something that
god made the way
in christianity god made adam but that
jesus is god that they are
that there's a they have communion that
would you take
communion that you are taking into you
actual material of god
these are from a physics standpoint from
a theoretical physics standpoint a
quantum physics standpoint
enormously sophisticated concepts
that something can manifest itself in
three
very different ways it's a it's at um
god uh not duality but whatever the
triple version of us triality right
uh you know wave particle duality we
accept as physical
and in that particular religious
tradition there's a there's an analog
it's a three-part analog that god
depending on how you're looking for god
you will find depending what kind of
experiment you conduct
god the father jesus christ the son
or the holy spirit and yet nobody would
say those
no christian theologian would say that
they are anything other than the same
thing just as no modern physicists would
say
that the electron oh yeah yeah it's a
it's a totally different thing when it's
a wave than when it's a particle no it's
the same thing
it's just being perceived in a different
way and that
given that christianity came to it uh
almost not quite two thousand years but
but
but many centuries before physics came
to it
the notion that how you look for
something
shapes what your experiment will will
uh demonstrate to you is really quite a
fascinating
parallel yes in the abrahamic tradition
what is referred to as god
is similar as the dao or as brahman
or as we like to say with entheogens
that we unleash god within and that's
why
saint francis of assisi said that what
you are looking
for seeking externally
is actually what is itself looking
so we are looking for what is looking
and that's why we see the
the pursuit of the exogenous happiness
the exterior happiness but really
that well of honey of peace
and happiness is internal
it's just covered under this rock of the
contracted
egoic separate entity
and that's been one of the perennial
wisdoms as much as i
i actually agree with what you said
there a lot which is that
we undergo this process of both the
perennialism which is really important
but also the importance of the
particularity at the same time
is really crucial i think a good place
to take this now would
be the conversation about the
synthesis of science and spirituality
into one and this is becoming more and
more
critical and important because they are
ultimately one
but they got you know in an apparent
last 500 years
split into two in a way where
that the post enlightenment has said
that
oh well science is its own style
of scientific method and following a
specific
protocol about the investigation of the
of the
of matter and of materialism whereas
the spiritual investigation is typically
the investigation
inward the investigation into
consciousness
and the investigation into maximizing
one's own
peace and and happiness so how do you
feel
i know you've written a lot about the
relationship between
the spirituality and science so how do
you feel about where it's at and also
where we're heading
on synthesis yeah it's a very
interesting question you know
uh as a an evolutionist obviously i have
to admire stephen jay
gould but as a theologian he was an
idiot
he wrote uh you know uh about
science and religion being
non-overlapping magisteria being
two realms of uh intellectual inquiry
that could not ever find a common ground
and i think that was idiotic i think
that was
um the kind of
view of religion that many an atheist
comes to without ever having actually
read much theology or engaged with many
people of faith
uh they say oh you know we're based on
logic we're based on evidence we're
based on an empirical
uh proof well you know doubting thomas
wanted some empirical proof do you want
to put his hand
into christ's wound to see whether or
not what christ was
was saying was true uh they're an awful
you know
it's not a question of one is just
blindly accepting
and the other is this kind of very uh
cynical demand for proof um
i think that the questions are so
complex
why are we here where did we come from
where are we going what does the future
hold
is there a purpose to it all that
bringing all the tools to bear
yeah is a much more sensible way than
saying
that this narrow uh selection of tools
is the only way that said
when they contradict each other which
they sometimes do
my money is on a replicable
reality but even that is an act of faith
you know
we take as a given that two
experimenters
conducting the same experiment at
different locales at different times
will get the same result that the
universe functions
with immutable physical laws from moment
to moment and pretty much from place to
place
that's a that's a an assumption that we
you know in the even
centuries that we've been doing
experiments is such a tiny fraction of
the
13.77 the new current figure as of this
week
of how old the universe is 13.77 billion
years
a tiny fraction to say oh yeah we
understand that the laws of physics have
been
always the same the same place in the
same time
i think that anybody who's grappling
with the questions should be applauded
and the only people who i have no
patience for
are the ones who don't think that the
questions are worth even
asking yeah um the you know it's a
really good question
why are we here uh it may be
that we're not here for any reason at
all that everything was a random
fluctuation in a vacuum
that may even turn out to be true but we
don't know
that it's true and to be close to the
possibility
that there's a purpose to it all seems
as much a faith-based position
i take this as a given that there's no
reason to at all
as uh any dogmatic religious position
might be
and both of them should be rejected
dogma should always be rejected in favor
of
uh a questing
yeah thank you
the word exploration is the one that
really comes as something that
is all-encompassing
in many ways and even play
play is another one to explore and to
play
is a good all-encompassing
reason for what this is
and what the word eternity and
infinity are is that this
these types of
play and exploring have always been
happening
and that this is what that is and that
that's style of uh
as you were discussing earlier
pre-object
permanence there is a style of
infinity and eternity and peace and
playful radiance from these toddlers
that is just radiating
and it's just so beautiful and then
somehow
there's a style of an egoic contraction
that occurs especially with the
um the sort of economic machinery
that is uh in a sense very
indoctrinating
um people into said 40 hour a weeks
just to be able to have the financing to
pay for the roof over their head and
whatnot
so there's a whole boatload of changes
that are being architected in order to
be able to
maximize the exploration and the play
component
of it and another important topic for us
to talk about
is on the future of humanity side
of things something that you and i
are both really passionate about
figuring out
is sort of what is this
will you we can use this term metaverse
it's been
sort of helpful for for me and
by definition for what i understand it's
something along the lines of
the synthesis of things like artificial
general intelligence the
indistinguishable virtual realities
the biotech and neurotech like the
neural links and whatnot
and so is where we are going
a style of metaverse and
are we going to continue doing things
like exploring and playing in these new
indistinguishable realities that we
immerse ourselves into that we'll have
so many cool
new designers and new ways to play and
immerse ourselves into
and is this also potentially what that
already is
are we already doing that
you know as we um talk
just a few days since there was the
storming of the
u.s capitol building um
by a mob and when you look at the news
coverage of that
it's nowhere near as exciting as
avengers endgame
it's nowhere near as exciting as the
latest mission impossible film
or the climactic battle of star wars and
yet it's infinitely more gripping
because we understand that it's real
as opposed to fake just a few guys
clambering up you know the the
walls of the building that's not
super exciting in and of itself but the
consequences the gravitas of the fact
that it really was happening
and happening at the people's house in
the uh
you know the capital of the most
powerful nation on earth
made for many of us made it incredibly
riveting viewing um
and we will if we aren't already at the
stage we soon will be at the stage where
we'll be able to create
simulations and virtual realities
immersive experiences
that are indistinguishable from reality
but still i think that there is going to
be
a fundamental part back here in the
amygdala or somewhere in the middle of
the brain there
asking that really important question
is this real or is this fake is it live
or is it memorex
and the fact that if it ain't live if
it's fake
if it's a simulation we respond our
brains respond
in a different way oh wow man all right
you know it's it
way more exciting watching bruce willis
uh defend uh
you know the um uh the nakamoto tower
whatever it is and uh
die hard then it is watching the dc
police
defend the senate chambers
but one may be more visually exciting
but the other one has that gravitas of
reality
associated with that so i wrote a line
many many many years ago
it came out and one of my novels came
out terminal experiment 1996
virtual reality is just air guitar writ
large
it will always be fake no matter how phi
del how how much high fidelity there is
how much fidelity there is
no matter what level of resolution
including you know we're talking now and
making motion pictures at um
we already have some like how will you
be able to tell that though
well that's an interesting question
right that is a very interesting
question because of course those who
would argue we're in a simulation right
now
and we've bought into its reality
and that's and that's so funny because
that's also the synthesis of
you know the spirituality with the
science
yes the question is you can
fool the cerebellum you can fool the
most highly developed part
of the human brain but i don't think you
can fool
the reptilian part you can can't fool
the amygdala you can't fool the part of
the brain
that somehow recognizes
reality versus falsehood there's a
reason why
no matter how exciting grand theft auto
or whatever
game you're playing is you still don't
get the fight-or-flight response the
adrenal rush
that you would get in a real car crash
situation
um oh part of our brain that
is not maybe self-awarely conscious
is the is the part that mitigates
whether or not
something is reality for us
rob maybe it has something to do with
the again it's so fascinating
science and spirituality whether we call
it a simulation or a dream
so fascinating first of all and the
indistinguishable
immersion into it real or fake
uh whatever those mean and then
it's so interesting if there is a
sovereign
control if rob
or atlas have a sovereign control
in in a sense being able to do something
like when you have your
your games and you have all of your you
know 100 different games
on the console and you can at any moment
click the
the save button and then switch over to
another game
which literally means i would you know
pause
this save it and then go into a
completely different
environment in a completely different
like we were talking about all the
different creation designs and all the
different
realities that it could potentially
exist and immerse myself into that one
and begin playing there and then switch
between them
so maybe in a sense part of it has to do
with
one's ability to whether you can
decipher whether it's uh
real or not could have something to do
with your ability to have sovereignty in
clicking the button
and switching between different games or
in this case if we're immersed in this
80-year game
straight that then this one
doesn't have that ability to click the
save button and switch to a different
game
something like that just something yeah
you may very well be right and
you know there is our
consciousness but there also is our you
know our microbiome
which also is alive and there's a degree
to which you can easily fool
me by and large i mean we don't yet have
for instance we don't
simulate in our virtual reality
pheromones or even just smells very well
that if i stop and ask myself am i
really
in toronto which is where i am you just
go right there really
you know in the vatican square how real
is this
smell under the armpit yeah right am i
surrounded by
10 000 other people in vatican square
right now
no there's nobody else in this room i
can tell there's nobody else in this
room
whereas i could smell a crowd you know
if i make the effort as richard feynman
discovered you know we talk about humans
having
almost no sense of smell compared to
dogs and he went around
sniffing all kinds of things and said
you know you actually you just ignore it
yeah our reality is we don't pay much
attention to smells but if you start you
can say
yeah somebody has been handling this i
can smell the sweat the salts
that their skin sweat has left on this
metallic object
uh if i actually attune myself to paying
attention to it
so i can convince myself visually that
i'm cr surrounded by 10 000 people
um but my microbiome says no rob's all
alone we don't have to
do whatever um modification
or moderation of rob's behavior that is
always going on you know with all the
the little bacteria going on saying you
know rob should be
more anxious or rob should be more calm
or rob should be this or
all of which really does happen right
that there is an interplay between
you know this entity and and and the gut
bio and all of that
just as there are you know the uh uh all
the bacterial things that can take over
um
ants or amoebas or whatever and cause
them to
modify their behavior so whatever
simulations we have we are not yet
simulating something where the whole
body is buying into the simulation
all of the the possible entities that
make up the individual
and then would that then potentially
lead to
the again very spirituality and science
coming together
where you have the oroboros the snake
eating its
tail and then the
[Music]
recursion in science as you could say
the procedure calls on itself so reality
calls on itself
and so in the sense of the transcension
hypothesis
that idea from john smart the idea that
we go inward
we go in to these indistinguishable
virtual worlds and we continue that
that cyclical and that's why even you
know sir roger penrose
won the nobel prize in physics in 2020
and he has a cyclic cosmology so
even the cutting edge of science is
beginning to be like okay
we some of the spirituality stuff yeah
the cyclic eternal
exploration yeah play yeah and you know
i mean
i actually know penrose a little bit i
had a great privilege of speaking with
him
uh uh we were all speakers at a
conference in tenerife a few years ago
um and you know it it's funny because it
comes back to her because of course
one of the questions that everybody asks
every big bang
theorist is well what was there before
the big bang and stephen hawking kind of
wants to say
well that's an unformable question you
know you can't answer that
because and penrose says no the easiest
answer
is it's cyclical right so there was
always something before
and there's always something after and
that intuitively is way more satisfying
than when
a physicist like hawking uh will say
you know your question
is irrelevant uh no it's a really good
question what happened before the big
bang
and i i'm not at all surprised that
penrose and others have come around to
this
cyclical notion because it makes so much
intuitive sense um compared to the
notion that
well before the big bang there was no
time so you can't ask what before this
but
you kind of can't ask it if we can ask
it if we can
we talked earlier about this ability for
us to imagine things
beyond the newtonian reality if we can
formulate the question
you're begging it you're saying well
that's not a good question
is not a satisfactory intellectually or
emotionally satisfying answer
if i can ask the question then your
conception of reality is flawed
if you can't answer that question other
than to say well your question makes no
sense
it only makes no sense because you
haven't got a sufficiently
robust paradigm that you're trying to
voiced upon
would you
say with a fairly high certainty
that the
decentralized swarm unilinear
evolution that's occurring that
orthogenic style evolutionary process
is just heading towards both the
that expansionary exploration
of the cosmos as well as that
inward transcension exploration of these
indistinguishable virtual worlds
that's a really good question
evolution is not teleological doesn't
have an end in mind
it's always contingent about what the
circumstances are at the moment
and yet it's produced
every epoch
more complexity than existed in the
epoch before that
was never a step backwards never in our
cosmological history
have we looked and said oh yeah the
universe was you know
really it was all monolithic at the big
bang and then there was the
you know photon decoupling we don't say
you know and then about
11 billion years ago it got simple for a
while
and then got more complex again it has
always successfully become more and more
complex more and more you can talk about
entry more more
randomness more and more chaos or
disorder but
in terms of biology there's no stage in
the history of life
where life went sort of okay you know
having having complex life is going to
take a hiatus for a while
and we're going to move back towards
unicellularism it never happened that
way
so there is some kind of inertia
that we try to explain or explain away
when we talk about
evolution and cosmology it definitely
trend tends toward not even tends
towards it absolutely
at every step of the way moves towards
higher levels of organization
of consciousness of biological
sophistication
you know we all think it'd be terrifying
to be chased by a tyrannosaurus
the reality is that guess what a good
mammal can outrun even me and outer
shaped
60 year old guy can outrun a
tyrannosaurus because i've got the
benefit of 65 million years
of evolutionary honing of what biology
can do what biochemistry
can do beyond what the tyrannosaurus had
i've got a much more efficient
uh biology of metabolism than
any reptilian even an archaesorian
reptilian like a
like a dinosaur has i can outrun it i
can outrun it
sustained running for a longer period of
time and a good human athlete
you know can run circles around it uh
you know
today's tiger would take down the
tyrannosaurus easily
right it moves forward and it gets more
complex
and that is something that it's really
hard to
dismiss um
under our you know we want to dismiss it
and say well that doesn't figure in to
our physical
conception of reality but it does seem
to be an
inalterable part of the universe we live
in that it tends towards
higher levels of intellectual
organization
higher levels of life forms higher
levels of structural complexity
yeah i've also found the
the attractor that the complex
system evolves towards to be fascinating
to
hypothesize as that recursive godhead
and that
another sort of
beautiful way of exploring it is like
what we were talking about earlier which
is this is the
bayesian cloud this is that big
probability space that leads up to
where we're going and all the different
the possibilities may even exist across
all these other
designs of of realities that are
happening
i want to ask you a question that
is really important
creatively so the way that
i've
undergone the process of
creating and writing and
just formulating is i've taken this
sort of approach which is called this
sort of
diamond approach which is kind of this
idea of like this 10
10 chapter framework and so it's like a
lattice work
in a sense of these 10 chapters and then
or
five or however many somebody wants to
go with but the point is is that i
i do it in 10 let's say and then what
happens is each one of them has
a sort of header and so for me like
chapter 9 was consciousness and chapter
10 was
infinity right and stuff like that and
so the point is is that
under then consciousness i would then
have a bunch of
really good both writings that i've done
visual illustrations that i've done
right
and then over time i'm basically just
synthesizing and distilling
synthesizing and distilling more and
more
and so i'm curious about the process
being such a award-winning author
is what is the process for you
around being able to creatively express
your stories what kind of a framework or
process
do you follow that enables you to sort
of synthesize and distill
over time the essence of what you're
creating
well for me i'm very much a top-down
writer so i have to have
my thematic statement before i can
do any of that stuff you know they teach
you in creative writing class wrongly
make up a character write a character
sketch write a bio
you got to have something to say and
that synthesis has to come
first you really have to have whatever
it is you're writing about whether it's
you know quantum physics like i read
about my novel quantum knight
or artificial intelligence like i read
about my novel wake for instance
uh you have to have really
immersed yourself in everything that is
said on that topic
by all kinds of different people and
come up with a synthesis now your
synthesis may or may not be the same
from book to book i've argued you know
that ai is both an
existential threat and probably our
savior in different books right
but for a given book you have to come up
with
this is what i want to say and once you
know what you want to say
it becomes fairly straightforward to
devise what characters are going to say
it
for you you don't want any of them to be
strong men or women you don't want any
of them to just be there to be knocked
down
what you find in any sophisticated
discussion
is that the various point of view
holders
are sophisticated in and of themselves
the easiest discussion
is to pit capitalism against socialism
and make one of them a strong man
and knock it down the complex discussion
is you know there's
a lot of value to capitalism there's an
awful lot of value to socialism
too there's a lot of really bright
people who are advocates on
either side of both of them what can we
say
that makes sense as fresh and new and
exciting
about economics as an overall topic
without saying capitalism good socialism
bad or vice versa
which is you know so much of our
discourse today on whatever
polarizing topic you want to have ends
up being
this is the one true answer versus this
is this only a stupid person could
believe that
you know bernie sanders is not stupid to
believe in socialism
uh thomas piketty is not stupid to
believe in capitalism right they are
a very distinct economic models but they
both are really bright guys who are
exploring
how those two systems can survive in the
21st century
i'm afraid speaking of capitalism i do
have a
business call that i have to take in
just a couple of minutes yeah well we'll
log we'll
wrap this up i love what you just said
there because it's so
deep and true with me as well one of the
chapters in the first book i published
as well was around the sorting algorithm
and that very much has to do with the
you've mentioned this as well throughout
the conversation you want to we want to
drain the dirty bath water
but we want to keep the babies and we
want to bring them together into one
and on the spirituality one that's like
the dogmas and the fundamentalism
and then on the science one that's some
of the perverse incentives but we want
to bring them together the scientific
method
the hierophanies we want to bring them
together into one and so like you
described there with
capitalism socialism very similar drain
the dirty bath water bring the two
together into one indigenating modernity
usa and china left and right in the usa
politics it works across
the board and so to do that that's
that's a brilliant style yeah
taking the essence at the first and then
sort of breaking it down into what are
the
sub components that i can illustrate
excellent absolutely absolutely
and you know we are so fortunate
to live at a time where
we have really sophisticated science
we have really sophisticated philosophy
we have really sophisticated theology we
have really sophisticated
governance studies we have really
sophisticated
sociology we live at a time where
it's almost impossible to be conversant
with
all those separate fields and yet a
synthesis of them gives us the best
opportunity to really understand
reality in a way that a century ago
before quantum physics
or five centuries ago before any kind of
modern economic theory
or 2 000 years ago before much of the
terms of the way of
modern you know philosophy um
we wouldn't have been able to grapple
with reality we are fortunate to live it
really at the very first time in human
history
where we have sharp enough tools on
every intellectual front
to finally start to really answer some
of these fundamental questions it's a
wonderful time to be alive
100 love that great rap
totally yup synthesis is the future in
so many ways and so
absolutely i love that rob thank you so
much for joining us on the show this has
been such an honor and pleasure
my pleasure atlas live long and prosper
be well
and uh take care my friend thank you
thank you rob for joining us thanks
everybody for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
like the video subscribe if you haven't
already share with other people that you
think
could be positively influenced by it
again check out all the links in the bio
below
sfrider.com also rob's twitter profile
go and check those out go and support
him do check out his books thanks so
much for tuning in everyone we love you
very much we'll see you soon
bye everyone